hte driving equipment Well, first of all, I
left after two years, I have a
four-year plan at Tesla and it was
pretty good, so looking back it's definitely
good anyway, but of
course you didn't know at the time how great
it would develop and
I wasn't that visionary  I actually
firmly assumed that
Tesla would develop like this because there
were so many problems in day-to-day business that you thought it
couldn't work that way. I
sold all of my shares that were vested immediately
and I now have all my money
in the company again, that means I am
also my own investor, so
I also invested in the rounds of
the Series A seed funding round
as a normal investor in addition to,
I would say, founder shares, which I
also have, that means
I can say that 95 and more  Perz of
my networth are in the are in
my
company